uh can we go can we see a show the scene
of the movie where you get to see a
Sam's stroke game
I was waiting for Twitter to do it but
all right we'll do it here okay so
there's a there's a bachelor party we're
all part of like a Jonah Hill's friend
group right
and
and uh right now where I when it's not
anything in Vegas it's like Palm Springs
or some [__] where we shot it but we're
supposed to be in Vegas for the purposes
of a movie I think the girls are in
Vegas oh the girls the girls are in Palm
Springs okay so then we're in the hotel
room before we go out partying and
there's just like a montage of us doing
drugs and having fun but there are a
couple funny moments with blow up dolls
let's just let's just watch it and see
what happens yeah Sam it's just I don't
know what exactly we can include on
YouTube so some of this might get cut
out or it might get silenced but you can
always go watch the movie where though
maybe on Netflix
now no big deal but like an absolutely
smash [__] hit when it comes to the
numbers the craziest cast I've seen in
comedy in years like the cast is crazy
little duvals in the background of this
scene I mean just everybody it's
unbelievable all right you want to watch
it yeah
so what were you thinking in that what
was the motivation like how yeah how do
you prepare for a scene like that I
think in in in every like uh acting
experiences there's a moment where your
integrity is going to get tested you
know what I mean where they're gonna be
like hey do something really silly and
uncomfortable and you got to be like am
I making this movie or am I not making
this movie yeah yeah so I I definitely
didn't want to do it I definitely was
like this is stupid bro so then there
was like a decision had to be made in
the moment yeah do I try to stroke for
real
that sounds crazy that sounds crazy or
do I just make it look crazy and I was
like and if you notice my favorite part
I'm kind of at the level
I was like we're not playing that game
no I watched the video watch she's not
[__] the position
um
and you just get your dick just
that's a great way to say you're eating
ass though I'm eating box backwards
backwards
I fell asleep in box and woke up acting
choice no big deal
[Music]
ah
yeah you see him in the corner still
going for it yeah yeah I mean
yo this is what's weird about those
scenes is like
you're doing a scene there's no
direction and you're seeing like the
other acting folks like the people
actually know how to act going for it
hey because they're like I'm Gonna Get
You Know noticed in this scene so you're
like okay how could I be
creative in this scene and do something
that will stay but then it does start
digging at you it's like do I need to be
seen in the scene without talking and
there's just a doll and you're there
probably how many hours of practice oh
we're there for the whole day he said
just the whole day to just think about
it yeah
eight seconds you feel like you don't
want to try too hard you don't it's not
try to learn but it's like bro I don't
look corny I don't want you it's still a
comic you're like this is
[__] plastic dolls
like we said funny things
when I watch it I'm like oh this looks
funny but I can't even imagine the
awkwardness in the room when it's quiet
the worst is like you're doing it's not
even your coverage the camera ain't even
really on you it's like kind of on you
like do I really need to eat the [__]
of a doll from behind from behind and
like you just see the back of my head
like what am I doing with my life what I
loved about this is like you look like
you got shoulder pads on like yeah
[__] that foot though I mean there
were lines to this oh yeah we had some
lines we had some yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
I mean this made it in the movie
this is this is a beautiful moment this
is uh I think it's one of the best
scenes for the movie in my opinion
yeah I stormed the capital
what did you think of his decisions
there you're a good actor so I'm curious
what'd you think of what he did I
thought I thought he pulled it off I
thought for the situation
there's a situation
she's an amazing actor
it was just very cool that Kenny let you
ad-lib and a very smart choice to just
play yourself I thought that was great
yeah yeah I thought that was awesome
when you went to January 6 you were just
like method acting like trying to
prepare for the road I was trying to get
up in there bro I was trying to get up
in there 100 100 it was just preparation
for the road chasing down Pelosi bro oh
really yeah
we'll did a little party you want to go
Hells yeah yeah right it looks like
there's a bunch of white people doing
something oh no not not that like
not that part I wanted to change the
course of America
yeah no in the same way that like like I
want to go to a Billy Joel concert I
don't listen to Billy Joel but people
geek out over Billy Joel that's what I'm
saying there's a bunch of white people
that gather they're hyped and they doing
some yeah